[Music]
we all remember our favorite toys from
childhood and we usually remember them
fondly that's why this video might be a
bit scary today we are looking at toys
that just might have been possessed by
ghosts be warned it gets pretty spooky
make sure you stay to the end to see
something that reminds us of a real-life
version of a character from a modern
horror classic if this is your first
time watching one of our videos then
make sure to give this one a like and
hit the subscribe button here are 10
haunted toys caught on camera thrift
store doll mystery have you ever bought
something because you thought it was a
bargain and then regretted it like not
because you didn't really have the money
or because you didn't have quite enough
space in your home but because there was
something inexplicably wrong with it
that's what happened to one woman when
she picked up a doll from a thrift store
debbie merrick picked up three china
dolls for a pretty cheap price just five
pounds because she thought that they
would be worth more but that turned out
to be a mistake when her husband Cameron
woke up with mysterious scratches on his
legs Debbie from Kingsland UK said her
family's homes fire alarms had been
going off mysteriously after they bought
the Regency style dolls in July 2017 she
thought that it was a spirit that lived
inside the dolls was moving through the
house and causing some pretty spooky
problems we can't think of any other
explanation so we think she did the
right thing when she sold the dolls
online but the story doesn't end there
the dolls new owner Lee steer had a
similar experience his father Paul woke
up in his room in Rotherham UK with
scratches along his arm shortly after
the possessed figurine turned up using
an online application he discovered the
dolls name was Samantha and it wanted to
strike Lee it looks innocent but
thinking about it gives us the shivers
hey guys please check out the most
awesome sisters on YouTube sister fun
watch can play the latest games go on
amazing adventures and just doing all
sorts of fun and silly things if you
have kids
little brothers or sisters or if you
just want to join in on the family fun
please subscribe to their Channel
natural creeping babydoll
sometimes something doesn't have to be
necessarily haunted to be pretty scary
there can be a certain something that
makes what ought to be a normal and
innocent thing a bit unnerving and
that's certainly the case with the next
toy it dates from 1871 and well just
look at it it's like something from our
worst nightmares it's a doll but then
again it use it it's got the head of a
baby doll
and the arms and legs have one too but
it's what's in the middle that makes us
shiver
it's a bizarre mechanical contraption
that looks kind of dangerous and it's
aged means it's got rusty which makes
things even worse it's supposed to crawl
along but the thought of it moving just
know do you know what's even worse when
it was made the word crawling with
interchangeable with creeping and that
means it's called the natural creeping
baby doll which seems pretty appropriate
it was created by American inventor
George Pemberton Clarke it's brass
clockwork body is supposed to imitate a
crawling action we wouldn't want it to
be coming towards us on a dark night or
anytime of the day for that matter it
would seem as if it were haunted oh and
there is a piece of wood on top of it
that makes it look less like a doll and
more like some kind of spooky experiment
Robert the Haunted doll if you go to Key
West Florida pay a visit to the East
Martello Museum there you'll come across
information about the history of the
local area and its culture but there's
also something that can send shivers
down your spine inside a glass case
there's a warning out booking wooden
doll
the dolls name is Robert the story goes
that it was given to the artist Robert
Eugene Otto when he was a little boy in
1906 some reports say it was a servant
who practiced voodoo that gave it to him
but strange things happened involving
this doll
sometimes the boy would be involved in
accidents he had no explanation for for
instance his other toys would end up
being destroyed or broken he would blame
the doll this might sound like he was
trying to deflect attention away from
bad behavior but his parents heard the
boy talking to Robert which would answer
back it avoids quite unlike the children
sometimes when the family was out and
there was nobody in the house people
could see Robert looking out from
different windows Robert Eugene Otto
kept the doll with him in the house
till he died in 1974 even then people
who moved into the property could hear
footsteps and laughter from the
seemingly empty attic even when it was
donated to the museum it still gave off
an eerie presence people are still
encouraged to introduce themselves to
Robert just in case the doll that
inspired a movie thinking about the idea
of a haunted toy it sounds like
something that could come out of a
horror movie just think about it a
harmless and even friendly object that
can come to life
perfect for a late night scare fest well
here's something that inspired a series
of horror movies fans of scary films
might well be familiar with 2013's
the conjuring and its 2014 prequel
Annabelle in those films a demonically
possessed porcelain doll wreaks havoc on
a neighborhood if you've seen them
you'll know just how spooky the doll is
did you know it's based on a true story
the thing is though the real doll wasn't
made of China it was a cloth raggedy
Anne style toy we don't know why the
filmmakers changed it maybe it looked
scarier anyway in the 1970s Lorraine
Warren an occultist of Monroe
Connecticut was told by a pair of
nursing students they had been
terrorized by a child's toy it was said
to have moved around their apartment
leaving behind scratch marks and writing
cryptic messages the students said a
psychic had told them the doll was
possessed by the spirit of a dead
seven-year-old called Annabelle Higgins
however the Warrens did their own
research and found it was possessed by a
demonic spirit the original Annabelle is
in Lorraine's Museum in Monroe no one is
allowed to touch it and a priest has
been called on to say a prayer that
finds it devil baby doll New Orleans is
one of America's greatest cities its
history is a French outpost from the
Louisiana Purchase coupled with its
status as a cosmopolitan port city gives
it something that nowhere else in the
United States has but like any city
there are stories and legends to it and
some of them are pretty spooky one of
them is a tale that takes in voodoo toys
and a set of family heirlooms the so
called devil baby dolls were first
created from hollowed-out gourds and
placed outside cottages to scare off
evil spirits in the early 19th century
legendary voodoo practitioner Marie
Laveau warned against making them too
realistic
lest they anger the real devil babies
the reports calmed down until the start
of the 20th
trees that's when reports of real-life
devil baby dolls started to spread
through the streets of the cities they
were dressed in children's clothes and
had the same face one woman who said she
had seen the devil baby said it was the
same face as the demon they were seeing
throughout the city however not many of
them survived today some are kept locked
up as family heirlooms
however NOLA artist Ricardo puste Ianno
has the remnants of one which he used to
build a new ones replicas of this are on
sale and while we don't think they're
possessed we are still a bit spooked out
by them we just can't be a hundred
percent sure that they aren't haunted
that teddy that moves in the night this
is one of the most unnerving and creepy
things that we've come across it's the
tale of a normal average everyday teddy
bear which appears to move and act of
its own free will in the dark hours in
the middle of the night what makes it
worse is that at one point the toy bear
looks like it moves on to a sleeping
little girl the footage which is
believed to have been filmed in India
has attracted controversy ever since it
was first posted online in July 2016
the poster who has yet to be tracked
down says he believes that the toy bear
has been manipulated by ghosts but other
people have said that it is being moved
by someone hiding under the bed we are
more inclined to believe the former if
truth be known that's because the bed
isn't exactly very big so we aren't
entirely sure how someone could have
fitted underneath it what makes this
footage even more spooky is because it
was captured on an infrared baby monitor
the dark colors remind us of the horror
movie Paranormal Activity the matte film
certainly scared us one heck of a wat
the puppet that moved by itself if you
know one thing about puppets it's that
they are supposed to move that's kind of
the entire point of them whether it's a
marionette operated by strings or a
ventriloquist doll a puppet that doesn't
move isn't really a puppet at all at
least that's what we think but bearing
that in mind what if it moves and
there's no master of puppets to do so
then it might just be haunted that's
what happened in this case paranormal
investigator Jane Harris took on a case
one day and made a video to try to
convince skeptics Jane from Sturbridge
UK was told that an innocuous looking
puppet had tried to strangle its owner
as he lay in bed one night she took on
the doll which looks like an elderly
Victorian gentleman with white hair
glasses and a velvet waistcoat and put
it in her basement
she then focused a camera on it then she
left it for three months when she came
back
to it she got something that was
definitely really spooky the puppet was
kept locked inside a glass case but her
recording found that the doll had sat up
and slowly moved its operating cross
until it's at up there was no way it
could have been manipulated Jane said
she said she had never seen anything as
exciting as this we think the best word
is scary joliet this all collector this
next toy is one of the more mysterious
ones in fact there's so much that we
don't know about it however it's
certainly worth taking a look at if you
dare of course according to the story a
woman called Anna gee is the latest in a
line of women who have been hit by a
curse it is said that each woman of the
family will have two children a boy and
a girl
Vanden is said that the son will die
when he is just three days old Anna says
that her great-grandmother was given a
doll named Juliet when she was pregnant
she gave birth to a son who died when he
was three days old it's been said the
doll captures the souls of the boys in
the family and can be heard crying the
souls are cursed to stay inside the doll
until they can be made free on Judgment
Day but in order to protect them Juliet
has to be looked after by the women who
have to care for it like they would do
their own children it's pretty scary but
we have some questions such as where are
the family from why was the doll cursed
and have they ever tried to have more
than two children it's certainly a bit
bewildering and it opens up a lot of
questions it's still very spooky though
is it the bear or the house that's
haunted now this is a pretty spooky sort
of video but while we think something in
it is haunted we don't know what you see
the film shows a white teddy bear left
alone on some stairs
it's just sat there with nothing next to
it to disturb it next to a toy car but
you see the bear move to its side like
it is falling down then you see that the
little toy car then goes down the stairs
to we're pretty baffled by what is going
on there is the bear possessed by
something that's certainly feasible but
what about the car again it could happen
but here is another idea what if it's
the house itself that is haunted if it
is that we are dealing with a very
specific sort of ghost that sort of
ghost is called a poltergeist a
poltergeist is a spirit that has the
power to move things the name is kind of
a giveaway Pole turn is German for
caused a disturbance while Geist is
German for spirit they are often
believed to be the spirits who are angry
because they belong to people who died
young but we hope that you aren't going
to encounter any malicious goes by
the way did you know that Teddy's are
named in honor of former American
President Theodore Roosevelt he was a
renowned hunter who spared the life of a
baby bear and so the toys are named
after him Pennywise in doll form anyone
who's seen it will know that clouds are
just inherently spooky whether it's the
1990 miniseries or the 2017 hand horror
movie penny wise the dancing clown is
one of the scariest characters in
popular culture so whoever came up with
this doll well it's pretty horrifying we
have no idea whether it's actually
haunted or not but we can't think anyone
would have actually designed this it's
something we can't really think is
exactly suitable for children just look
at it it actually looks like a miniature
version of penny wise it's got the
jagged teeth it's got the white makeup
and it's got the shock of red hair just
looking at it gives us the shivers we
are worried that it is going to invite
us down to the sewers so it can feed off
our greatest fears by the way did you
know that Stephen King created penny
wise as an update of the classic
children's story the Billy Goats Gruff
that's right the scary cloud creature is
a modern update of the troll and rather
than cross a bridge the children walk
above the sewers the author says that he
was also inspired by the library in
Stratford Connecticut there was a
corridor between the adults and
children's section which reminded him of
the bridge but what we'd like to know is
who you think the scariest horror movie
character is and that's all for our 10
haunted toys caught on camera if you
liked it be sure to check out 10 amazing
pictures they won't show you in history
books thanks for watching
[Music]